well a possible war was serious seems
like an important news story but it's
not the important news story of the day
not the most important CNN revealed
their view of that this afternoon when
they cut away from nikki Haley at the UN
to this we must not overlook Russia and
Iran's roles in enabling the Assad
regime's murderous destruction Russia
and Iran have military fibers we're
gonna break away from Nikki Haley's
testimony before the UN Security Council
we have a breaking news just in The New
York Times just reported that the FBI
today raided the offices of president
Trump's longtime attorney Michael Cohen
well that raid reportedly is connected
to the stormy Daniels story CNN covered
wall to wall and of course throw me
Daniels is way more important than any
war with Syria that CNN's position is it
mark Stein's position he joins us
tonight author and columnist the
priorities become really clear you can
you cut from the UN we may go to war
stormy Daniels news breaking did you see
that yeah I I saw this new film
Chappaquiddick over the weekend and
after Ted Kennedy has his car accident
his dad Joe Kennedy calls in all the old
Kennedy fixes and they're thrilled
because Chappaquiddick happened at the
time that man was about to set foot on
the moon and so they thought oh this is
great if man sets foot on the moon for
the first time ever this will bury Ted's
car accident and will be ok you can bet
that if man set foot on the mood for the
first time and they raided Trump's
lawyer's office that Trump's lawyer's
office would absolutely crush one giant
step for mankind would bury it it would
be on the foot of page 37 and no one
would ever know man had landed on the
moon
that's the Brotherhood is over at CNN
none of you had stormy Daniels pictures
de compañía so what
it's as I said to you last time I mean
it was a perfectly good sex scandal and
now it's a hundred and thirty thousand
dollar campaign finance infraction that
Robert Muller and the FBI are going to
pursue to the ends of the earth if
necessary they don't care how many
millions at all as they spend nailing
some guy on a hundred and thirty
thousand dollar campaign finance
infraction I like my sex scandals to be
about sex not about campaign finance
it's way less appealing when it becomes
campaign finance related all right so I
know you followed news from the UK the
Mayor of London Sadiq Khan is now not
making this up value a crackdown on
knives cutting implements following a
crime wave there
he said quoting there's never a reason
to carry a knife and vowing to punish
all who do meanwhile in New York in
related news bill de blasio aide regan
stevens was arrested after she was
caught with an illegal handgun in her
car what are these add up to other than
like the end of civilization well it's
it's interesting to me in Britain
because I believe the national cutlery
Association has come out strongly
against background checks for people who
want to own knives and you know they're
they're they're thinking that you know
people if you outlaw knives only outlaws
will have knives and I use the term
cutlery seriously because people use
what's to hand I was in a French village
two summers ago and a lady and two of
her daughters were felt to be were in
their bathing suits and and the Mohammed
next to them went full Allahu Akbar
stabbed them with a fork the fork he was
having breakfast with and a helicopter
had to fly in and helicopter the wounded
to a hospital in Grenada people use
what's to hand and the reality in London
as Katie Hopkins said on your show a
couple of nights ago
is that 85% of last month's stabbings
both perpetrators and victim
basically the result of modern
immigration policies and and that to tie
what you were talking about with the
general about the border that's the
issue if you don't have a border if you
don't have a security perimeter at the
border you wind up having to have
security perimeters over everything else
including cutlery displays in London
supermarkets when you have a population
they can't control itself you can't have
rights actually is the knob so what
deblasio's aid gets caught with an
illegal handgun is this like peta
running a butcher shop I mean this is is
there anything more hypocritical than
this
yeah because basically this is his
advisor on criminal justice matters and
she's in a car that's filled with
marijuana smoke with a handgun on on
which all the identifying marks have
been have been rubbed off and I think
this again this gets to a point that we
come back to time and again that
increasingly we live in a land where the
laws don't apply to certain people you
know he'll pull some strings she'll
skate and if you're connected if you're
part of the governor's or a mayor's
detail you'll be fine if you're if you
work for someone important you're fine
and if you're if you're just some guy
living in some subdivision you don't
need a gun you don't need nothing
and it's that division it's that
division is getting a class system no I
know that's awful
that's american-style that's totally
true in an economy to match right we had
more time